it's not the way forward and if we don't
reconnect to nature we'll just destroy
it again I want I want to try to bring
this to some sort of closure that
doesn't feel like I'm the most
depressing person you've ever listened
to and so I'm kind of battling in my
mind now to kind of get us back to this
space where we can say it is doomed
it's like unbridled optimism like I
don't really know where you don't know
where to go at this one um so let me
take you back to kind of where how do
you reconcile those two things and I do
it actually through my experience as a
physician in the ICUs and in the icy use
when I was practicing intensive Hospital
medicine I got the privilege of being
around human beings at the end of life
and I was so compelled by this
experience that I ended up getting
another subspecialty in hospice and
palliative care and dealing with
end-of-life things for for four years
with a hospice group and at the end of
the life we've termed it death and what
I've laid out for you today is the
possibility of the death of our species
in 70 years 100 years who cares it was
200 years it's still pathetic and so we
have we're looking at the last chapter
of life on Earth with our current course
of action but let me tell you about what
my experience has been in those last
moments with patients who are dying we
have the belief I think in our
subconscious because of the movies we
watch because of the TV shows we watch
because of our our big divorce from the
death process it's become sterilized you
have probably not seen many people die
you've probably not seen your loved ones
die on they've probably died in
operating rooms or a nice use or and
they died before you could fly across
the country and see them or be and so
very few human beings are now watching
this process of of death and it's
allowed death to be defined as an
endpoint as a contraction or a
disappearance rather than what I would
have actually seen it to be and what
I've seen it to be is a massive
expansion of consciousness of reality of
awareness and ultimately of love
and the most poignant examples of this
or people that actually die biologically
and we spend 15 or 30 minutes and ICU
resuscitating them with drugs and
shocking their chests like you see on TV
shows and everything else and we have a
dismal track record of pulling those
people act it's not like TV we lose the
vast majority its around 6 percent of
cardiac arrests and in the hospital will
actually be resuscitated and 6 percent
will survive 94 percent will die so you
have somebody who's now biologically dad
and you're artificially sustaining life
you've got them on a respirator you're
pounding on their chest and press and
you're pumping drugs in their vein to
try to get their heart restarted and
doing all of this and they've meanwhile
been in the ICU for a week or a few days
or weeks months in some cases before
they they have this moment and by this
time they've been isolated away from
humans for quite some time they're only
touched by latex gloves hands
only people with gowns on will come and
see them that masks on they haven't seen
a human face close up in months you know
they're so isolated and lonely and they
go into this moment on the other side
and and then we start working on them
and doing our code and and as the hero
depicted on TV you become that doctor
that pulls somebody back from that that
other side of the veil and it was
startling as you know I moved past my
internship and started be kind of senior
resident these environments and really
responsible for being around these these
patients for hours after these
experiences they all told such a similar
story on the other side of biologic life
and it had to do with that a little bit
of a typical story that you might see in
the movies or something where they saw a
white light and there's a sense of
expansion all this but there's one
sentence that that came back again and
again and I had one ICU shift that was
very weird I had the one ICU shift where
I worked for 36 hours shift and during
that that night and middle of my 36-hour
shift I see three people die and I bring
them all back when I sent my team and to
the last one of those three every single
one of them their first sentence had was
always why did you bring me back which
always kind of deflated Molly and said
that yeah
I said why did you bring me back and and
the variety was huge one of these was an
african-american pastor had had over 200
visitors in his icy room in the days
before he passed away and the other one
was you know this very isolated kind of
ostracized
gentleman in his communities I was dying
of complications of AIDS and then I had
this kid who was who had genetic defects
and all this stuff and he was dying of
complications of pneumonia because he
couldn't breathe that anymore because
his skeleton a cloud so you just
couldn't pick three different medical
cases or three different human beings
and every one of them first sentence
why'd you bring me back and then as they
start to get oriented and in tho and the
hours that follow they're telling their
loved ones I went into this space and it
was bright white light everywhere and I
in that moment felt completely accepted
for the first time in my life and that
was a unexpected sentence to hear out of
multiple accounts I felt completely
accepted for the first time in my life
so what do you make of that I think
we're all walking around lonely as hell
and our opportunity to rebirth because
death is not a not an endpoint it's a
transformation moment it's an expansion
beyond the limits of this frail biologic
shell that we carry around and the
instant that we step out of that we find
out that the universe embraces us in
every single second of our existence and
complete acceptance of who we are we are
enough in and of our own identity of I
am at every second of every point of our
existence and it's the disbelief of that
that's keeping us locked in these stupid
conversations we just had for last hour
and a half that is myopic conversation
in and out itself when you back up for a
moment say okay we're killing ourselves
but what if we need a death moment to
transform completely to let go of all of
the preconceived notions of what it is
to be human and to say you know what we
are beings of light and we are
completely accepted at every mode
including this moment when we would rape
the earth of what it were raping in it
when we would kill each other at the
rate we do when we would destroy the
entire ecosystem of a green
planet in the middle of black space when
we would have that level of hubris we're
still completely accepted and our
journey is somehow understood by
something more benevolent and more
complete than we can see as human beings
and so let's not beat each other up over
this issue let's not see this as a
failure let's see this is an obvious
next step in our journey and death is
the inevitable thing marching at us
that's going to say are you going to
wake up and see the transformation at
that moment of death and transformation
and you're going to say goodbye Homo
sapiens or you do it a moment before
that in the body before the doctor
starts the resuscitation are you gonna
say you know what what if we all looked
at each other in wonder and awe and said
you're enough I accept you completely I
want to be with you I want to live with
you I want to be a live period and if
it's with you then it must be on purpose
because we're in the same room and the
odds of that is zero and so we are here
seven billion of us showed up right now
which is really odd because I just laid
out a horrific story of what's happening
on the planet and yet seven billion of
those white souls that seconds after
death are going to realize that they are
who they've always been they're fully
accepted and they are moving in true
love and and that white light is the
love and they're in that space what if
we can transform before we die then
there's no reason to go to Mars there's
no reason to go anywhere else
because we will do absolutely every
single thing differently here on earth
and we do it differently by just that
simple recognition of I am Who I am you
are who you are that's enough and I
accept you completely and let's figure
out how to do this within the design of
nature there's enough energy there's
enough food there's enough soil there's
enough commodities there's enough
resources for everybody on the planet to
thrive at a level that's never been
experienced we cannot continue any form
of human economic systems that have ever
existed before and expect us to escape
the death moment we literally have to
reinvent everything and so if you are
under the age of 18 right now you are
the last
generation that may live to the fullest
extent of the human potential it is you
who are being called it's transformed
because you showed up right when you did
if my generation is to do anything it
was to say oh my gosh we're going in the
dry or wrong direction but my generation
doesn't have enough time now to turn the
boat around reinvent everything and so
our mission is not to inspire the
farmers that are currently fighting the
good fight it's to inspire their
children to do the right thing and do it
differently connected to new children
who are in the cities who are in the you
know tech world whoever wherever they
are connect those kids back give them a
sense of that unity give them a sense of
the oneness and give us all a sense that
this is the inescapable optimism as we
are going to transform period and it may
be I doubt up to the point of our death
or miraculously it might just happen
right before it that was one of the best
monologues I've ever heard of my life
pre-shift brother that was amazing oh my
god you're this incredible contradiction
in terms with the doomsday and the
optimism and the deep-rooted experience
and knowledge in science and yet
somebody with a vast capacity for for
spiritual exploration you're a wizard
you're against all our we all are and
that's the excitement that I have is you
you can't actually come close to the
science of atomic physics or
astrophysics or human biology without an
overwhelming sense of we are just so far
beyond logic we're so far beyond the
material world we are these entities
that are moving with such power and we
have been kept from that power and we've
been kept from it so that power can be
taken from us and consolidate in the
hands of a few
[Music]